All right, welcome to another Zoom call.
We got some questions that came in.
Make sure you chat in any other questions that you have.
And let's get started.
So just so you know, I didn't update the slide,
but we actually have a trouble with YouTube.
They actually banned our channel.
We got it up and running again.
So you can see some YouTube videos.
We had to put just about every video on private.
I tell you, you don't think the conspiracy is real.
Then you're not paying attention.
So it's pretty crazy.
So that means that I have a link
that on the website on how to get to the members videos.
We'll be pushed to the police for now.
You'll be pushed to the our new video site, which is videos dot
colors clinic dot com or something like that.
They have a link on the home page of the member site.
And I have a link on the Zoom call page of the member site.
Just so you know, may have some availability on YouTube.
But it's just it's a hit or miss thing right now.
So again, if you just join us, they literally shot our channel
down, took it off completely off.
Everything for a while, but hopefully we're back on right now.
OK, so to our questions, let's get going.
Think of positive things.
Do you think extensitant is a good supplement to take?
And if so, are there any cautions for a person with cancer
or for a person without cancer?
Yeah, well, the only caution with any supplement is purity wise.
And a lot of supplements that you get that you can get over the
color sort of, you know, some supplement house or something
like that might not be quality.
So it's purity is the most important thing when we're talking
about supplements, quality supplements.
Maybe you're buying a good quality extensitant company.
I don't see any harm in taking that for cancer.
Again, you don't necessarily want to be taking too many things,
but there's nothing wrong with adding that to your protocol.
I watched the truth about cancer program where a doctor was
treating cancer patients with raw pig or a creus.
Yep.
The doctor said it actually takes the protective coating off
of the cancer cell so that your immune system can kill it.
I don't know if you ever heard of such a thing, but if so,
you think there's a benefit to taking pancreatic enzymes
of some sort.
I don't remember who's asking this question, but I have written
about this in my book.
I also have multiple blog posts about it, multiple video posts
about this. This is enzyme therapy.
So enzyme therapy was developed by Dr. William Kelly back
in the 1950s.
And the only enzyme really that was available at that time was
pork pancreas enzymes.
So that's what he uses pork pancreas enzyme.
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a promoter of his.
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a medical doctor that broke off
the establishment and practiced in upstate New York.
For many, many years, he used Dr. William Kelly's work
manufacturer. He wrote a book on Dr. William Kelly.
And this is another book that he wrote about concrete cancer
using pancreatic enzymes.
He always used the pancreas pork enzymes.
Now we have those enzymes on our store.
They are through the company allergy research.
That is the exact product that Dr. Nicholas used.
And we use enzyme therapy for a lot of people.
However, I do think that enzymes have improved
over the decades and I wouldn't stick to something
just because it was the only thing available at the time.
No, the negative about using the pancreas pork enzyme alone
is that typically that therapy is taking a lot of them
that we're talking about upwards to 150 capsules a day
out of empty stomach.
So enzyme therapy in short is taking enzymes out of empty stomach
so that you're not using them to digester food
but you're hopefully absorbing them
because you're taking high quantities of them
and you'll have it excess amount of enzyme circulating
in your bloodstream.
And they can write down slash gobble up the waste layer
around the cancer so that your immune system could attack it.
So it's very beneficial.
We have a number of people doing enzyme therapy.
Now using the newer enzymes, you can typically use
a far lower dose.
We've had people with different cancers use enzyme therapy
with great success, so but I test for that on everybody.
So if I didn't recommend enzyme therapy for you,
it's because it didn't test but it doesn't mean
things you may feel led to do that.
So I have numerous blog posts on enzyme therapy.
I have much written about it in my stop by the cancer book
as well.
And there's some videos on this stop by the cancer course
and some videos on the website probably on enzyme therapy.
So I know it sounds gross but it's not gross.
It's just enzymes, it's pancreatic tissue with enzymes
and so there's nothing gross about it.
So it could be very beneficial.
I was thinking of adding B propolis to my supplements
as I've learned that it has anti-cancer properties.
I found it from a family owned farm in Mississippi
and it's, and it's suggest you take 500 milligrams
one to three times a day.
Your thoughts please, and thank you.
So B propolis can have a good immune stimulating property.
There's, you know, I actually take some
the pollen not every day but at least a couple of times
a week to help with allergies and we could help,
it can be an immune regulator.
So it helps balance the immune system.
It can be really good for autoimmune issues
because of its immune regulation property.
So it can, that could be, it could have good properties.
There's a lot of things,
anything that's going to be an immune regulator
or an immune stimulator is going to have cancer killing properties.
There really isn't much downside to taking it.
It's very natural, it's water soluble,
it will flush out of your system,
it's not going to overload your liver.
So there's nothing wrong with taking B propolis.
You can't get it in a liquid form to spray,
as a spray as well, there's thoughts of different forms
that should be given in there.
Can the right machine use to help with testicular pain
or any pain for that matter?
Always with anything, you always want to ask the question,
why, right?
So if I have testicular pain or if I have, you know,
kidney pain or if I have pain in my big toe,
you always got to go, why, and you want to treat the why?
So if I don't have, let's say if I don't have,
you know, if I know I have cancer, testicular cancer,
that's why I have pain, okay?
Then that's the reason why I just need to decrease the inflammation.
Can I use the right programs or pain?
Sure, can I use the right programs for inflammation?
So whatever you have paid,
some of the inflammation programs may be more appropriate to use.
So because lots of times pain is going to be caused
from inflammation, you also are asking the question,
why, why do I have inflammation too?
So you always want to treat the reason why.
So if I am pain in an area, you want to try to figure that out.
If it can't be explained through something
that you know you have going on,
you may want to dig into to see what is actually happening.
Remember, whatever I've paid in any area in your body,
it can be referred pain.
So let's talk about testicular pain.
It's, I'm, I don't know, I think maybe that's your dental nerve.
It's coming out of your lower liver or sacral area.
Could the pain be referred because I have prostate cancer
because I have, so if I have pain,
due to something going on,
I got that, that a favorite fiber is going to fire back
into my spinal cord where it crosses my spinal cord
and synapses to an ascending a favorite fiber.
And it's going to go up to my final low neurology there.
It can fire back and you can get referred pain.
That's a referred pain is somewhere else in the body.
So you can get a referred pain that has nothing to do
with the area where you're having pain.
So investigating why you have pain is important
because it might not have anything to do with your testicle
or your big toe or your gut.
It could be how you could be getting referred pain
from something else.
So you want to investigate that.
That's why you, you know, you do, you know,
labs and scans and x-rays and things like that
to make sure you don't have something to wait on.
And if let's say you have really bad testicular pain
and your cancer that you're dealing with is like,
I don't want to say liver cancer,
it doesn't mean you can't have more than one thing going on
at the same time.
So it'd be good to get that examined.
We have a number of patients that might even be on this call
that have two or more different cancers.
So now we have a testicized cancer.
Let's say if you have breast cancer and a testicized
to your lung, it's still breast cancer.
We should go to have two different cancers.
And we have several patients that have two different cancers.
Lung cancer and breast cancer, totally different cancers.
Unrelated to one of them.
So, but also you can have other things going on.
Other than they can cause testicular pain,
pain is blockage that can cause inflammation.
So you want to get those things checked out
to make sure you're not just using the right machine
to cover up something also.
You don't want to use any nutrition
or any natural things to cover up
what your body's trying to tell you.
So you want to investigate to the cause.
I have a double mastectomy scheduled for April 5th.
I've read your post regarding tumor removal and fasting
to dial regulate MTOR and IGF post surgery.
Should fasting start the day after surgery.
I would start the day of surgery.
So that's when I will start the day of surgery.
And to at least a 24 hour fast,
maybe even a 48 hour for us,
but that's how you can tolerate it.
That can help you heal the best.
So, and then consider intermittent fasting
or time restricted eating after that.
So that you're getting a fasting like environment in your body.
So that you're not getting a formulation of it.
Should with which supplements should I continue
to take pre and post surgery?
Would you recommend Cheekswabs pre and post surgery?
No, necessarily maybe a conversation with me would be good
because then I could take a deeper dive
into your supplements that are going to last this question
and then I could give you an analysis
about that probably the best thing.
Would you recommend CBC or other lab tests
pre and post surgery?
I would certainly think that they would do that.
I would certainly think that they would do that
at the hospital post surgery.
You know, they would be hugely amiss
without making sure that your electrolytes aren't balanced
before letting you be dismissed from the hospital.
So yes, getting a CBC with complete metabolic panel
pre and post surgery would be appropriate.
You know, colleges has suggested starting to do oral chemo
with an estrogen blocker about two weeks post surgery.
So if you do make an appointment,
we could discuss that as well.
Last week I posed a question regarding nicotine patches,
IV applications, IV cancer.
You weren't familiar but said you'd look into it,
happy on the opportunity to do so.
I haven't had an opportunity to do a deep dive.
Of course, you can't find anything other internet
Google about this except negative things about nicotine.
I haven't got a chance to dive
into alternative approaches to that.
I would think that it's working on an oxidative stress issue
because at least my understanding of everything
that's out there research-wise nicotine
is it causes oxidative stress.
So you know, just a side note about that, you know.
That gets into should a cancer patient take antioxidant.
I think I talked about it the last week.
Zoom call, somebody asked a question about should all
breast cancer patients be able to do a thiode
and I said, no, absolutely not.
Blue di thiode is one of your strongest
intercellular antioxidants.
And you know, what chemo does is it works as an oxidizing agent
to kill cancer cells because cancer cells,
because they're rapidly replicated,
they're not producing adequate amounts of blue di thiode
so they're more susceptible to reactive oxygen species,
oxidative stress, any oxidative agents.
And that's why chemo can kill that directly.
So when you're just taking a whole bunch of antioxidants,
you could be supporting the life of cancer cell.
So it's all about balance with oxidative stress.
Lash antioxidant to block oxidative stress.
While oxidative stress can cause cancer,
antioxidants can prevent that oxidative stress cause of cancer.
Once a person has cancer and oxidative therapy,
maybe once in the best interest.
I mean, that's how leotryl works, B17,
that's how protocell works, that's how some other therapies works,
is they stimulate oxidative stress
or stimulate production of reactive oxygen species,
they're actually the cancer.
So no, not everybody should be on high dose at the antioxidants.
So I think that is the mechanism of action with the nicotine
is usually as an oxidative stress agent.
So it could be wrong,
but I think that's what makes the most sense
for my vet about the stimulants.
In the last three weeks, my ankles are swollen,
they are better in the morning.
Is it because of the kidneys?
I heard too much sodium potassium with phosphorus could do that.
Yeah, so getting CBC in a complete metabolic panel,
you could look at that and see if your electrolytes
are all the balance.
So any kind of imbalance in electrolytes
can affect the retention of fluid.
So your kidneys have stimulation by the forebode
produced in your pancreas that stimulates
the uptake of fluid and the release of fluid.
So if you have too much fluid that is being retained
and it's not being excreted by your kidneys,
then you could have an increased fluid in your extremities
or elsewhere.
Could be other reasons for that too.
Something as simple as posture while you're sleeping,
but they're better in the morning,
would be something that pissed the symptoms posture
while you're sitting.
So people are sitting at a desk all day
or people that aren't moving or people that are standing
on their feet all day.
It's really not a kidney function that's
they're getting fluid in their lower extremities.
It's a heart issue.
So as far as moving fluid out of the tissues
and into the limb system,
it's a function of muscular contraction.
But as far as pumping blood back
from your lower extremities,
that's a function of your heart.
So somebody with congestive heart failure,
weakening of the heart,
weakening of the strength of the heart contraction
is gonna have, you know, an excess
it's fluid in their extremities,
especially lower extremities.
So making sure you're moving,
you're sitting in a desk all day,
you're moving, your toe is moving,
your feet writing an alphabet,
that's your feet,
all these different lymphatic things
that we have written on some blogs.
So it's not always a chemical issue.
It can be postural,
can be hard,
can there's a lot of different possibilities.
That's what are your thoughts on the low carb keto diet
to reduce carbs and sugars
since cancer is a bit about disease
and its energy is driven by sugars and carbs.
I'm on an under 50,
carb, I think, 50 gram carb diet.
Oh, and eating plenty of protein, organic, free range
and plant-based things.
Yes, we write about that a lot.
You know, most cancers are going to find a fuel source.
The easiest fuel source is glucose.
So, and then they find the glucose,
they feed very,
cancer cells tend to feed very inefficiently.
Through the endpoint of glucose,
it's not through the crem cycle.
So they feed through lactate,
which is an anaerobic function of fuel source,
which is inefficient,
but it partly has to do with issues with the HIF1 gene.
Partly has to do with cancer cells,
rapid replication isn't producing
a lot of the enzyme to convert
peruvian acid into
acetyl quenzyme, that's the area to go into the crem cycle.
So it converts it to lactic acid
and it feeds off the lactic acid.
So, yes, going on a low carb diet,
a keto-like diet
and measuring your glucose.
Don't have to necessarily get into full ketosis,
but measure your glucose levels
and try to get your glucose down into the 70s.
Information has come out about how you have just
as good a success with a cancer patient,
but that's a try to get into full ketosis.
It's very difficult to be in full ketosis
and to stay in full ketosis.
And it's not altogether necessary.
So, if you can be on a keto-like diet
where you're getting your glucose levels down
as low as possible,
you could have just as good a success.
Measuring your carbs per gram can be really good,
but everybody's a little bit different.
So, I mean, you could be eating only 40 grams of carbs a day
and your glucose is still at 98,
fasting blood glucose to 98.
And this is where going on a
type of sugar need or some sort of modified faster diet
to help reset that metabolism can be beneficial.
So, measuring your blood glucose,
I think gives you a more accurate picture
of where your gram per day carbs should be at.
So, you also don't wanna go into a hypoglycemic state
where your blood glucose is down below 50 or something
like that and you're getting the shakes and all that
and the stuff.
So, measuring your blood glucose I think is a good way to go.
Any other questions?
All right, well, we will sign up for tonight.
Thank you all for being on.
And make sure questions in and we'll talk again next week.
All right, bye-bye.